Eudaimonia is an Ancient Greek word, particularly
emphasised by the philosophers Plato and Aristotle,
that deserves wider currency because it corrects
the shortfalls in one of the most central,
governing but insufficient terms in our contemporary
idiom: happiness. When we nowadays try to
articulate the purpose of our lives, it is
to the word happiness we commonly have recourse.
We tell ourselves and others that the ultimate
rationale for our jobs, our relationships
and the conduct of our day to day lives is
the pursuit of happiness. It sounds like an
innocent enough idea, but excessive reliance
on the term means that we are frequently unfairly
tempted to exit or at least heavily question
a great many testing but worthwhile situations.
The Ancient Greeks resolutely did not believe
that the purpose of life was to be happy;
they proposed that it was to achieve Eudaimonia,
a word which has been best translated as ‘fulfilment’.
What distinguishes happiness from fulfilment
is pain. It is eminently possible to be fulfilled
and – at the same time – under pressure,
suffering physically or mentally, overburdened
and, quite frequently, in a tetchy mood. This
is a psychological nuance that the word happiness
makes it hard to capture; for it is tricky
to speak of being happy yet unhappy or happy
yet suffering. However, such a combination
is readily accommodated within the dignified
and noble-sounding letters of Eudaimonia.
The word encourages us to trust that many
of life’s most worthwhile projects will
at points be quite at odds with contentment
and yet worth pursuing nevertheless. Properly
exploring our professional talents, managing
a household, keeping a relationship going,
creating a new business venture or engaging
in politics… none of these goals are likely
to leave us cheerful and grinning on a daily
basis. They will, in fact, involve us in all
manner of challenges that will deeply exhaust
and ennervate us, provoke and wound us. And
yet we will perhaps, at the end of our lives,
still feel that the tasks were worth undertaking.
Through them, we’ll have accessed something
grander and more interesting than happiness:
we’ll have made a difference. With the word
Eudaimonia in mind, we can stop imagining
that we are aiming for a pain-free existence
– and then berating ourselves unfairly for
being in a bad mood. We’ll know that we
are trying to do something far more important
than smile: we’re striving to do justice
to our full human potential and to work in
some small but key way towards the improvement
of our species.
At The School of Life we believe in developing emotional intelligence,
to that end we've also created a whole range of products to support that growth.
Find out more at the link on the screen now.